hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Muir now Emmure is a demo
for lovely that's not sinister at all
that's lovely now Emmure is a game that
is school I don't know I'm not
describing it well at all so this is a
game that is kind of like neverending
nightmares from what I saw in the
screenshots but maybe not no this is
well this oh no it is this is it the
place I saw in my dream I know she
wanted me to find it but why that's cool
okay well your picture of your wife was
all crossed out and I assume your wife
might be dead oh this is awesome oh this
is super cool
hello baby nice face look don't look so
good I guess there's nothing back the
way I came and I can't leave before I
get my answers okay alright losers
lounge on the couch for a bit a drawer
with an odd design on it looks like I
can open it okay do it then mm-hmm
a doorknob with an intricate design Oh
tab inventory cool oh this is neat Oh
also the mansion kind of reminds me of
amnesia the Dark Descent hello hello Oh
doorknob seems to be missing well maybe
this one
Oh doorknob come on put it on the thing
yeah no there we go got it oh that's
bizarre
what is this on the wall some kind of
painted door
why the thunderkick up right there huh
something about this weird door okay
I'll come back to that
some kind of magic door situation going
on here who put this here and why some
child okay Oh what was that I don't know
maybe you're losing it
this paint almost looks fresh hmm
worship chamber what are they worshiping
the helix fossile will okay I can offer
you power that voice this is what I saw
my dream The Shining troppa troppa so
hebron trapeze Oh he'd Rijn oh my god oh
that was so cool but also why I've got a
trap of Easterns it feels strangely
warmed at the touch and doesn't obey
reality as most objects do Oh
so you can just tell that just by
looking at it I don't really know much
about the shining trapa so he'd ruin
other than the fact that it holds
indescribable power I just know that
little anecdote about it I don't think I
would survive long without it but I also
can't shake this feeling that I would
have been better off not finding it
talking about oh my god I've got a trap
as of he'd ruin oh boy trapezoid Hren
for the hell is wrong with you okay
where am I now
who's moving over here shift to sprint
why do I need to sprint it always
happens that you tell me to sprint and
then something why do I need to hide why
do I need to hide why is this having up
tired down cross there's something going
on with this door right here of like the
shadows also okay try that didn't seem
to work huh
funny about that you know okay well oh
wait the pulse oh wait hang on a second
what the hell happened here Oh scp-682
bye-bye hey hey everything keeps
changing
I am Not Afraid of you
oh I'm afraid of you Oh what are you
[Music]
okay you could go away at any time now
that'd be great holy [ __ ] why are you
still here go away which is maybe I
gotta like duck out after he goes this
way okay so I think that's what I was
supposed to do I definitely probably
probably should that's not right that's
bad why would that be a thing that's
possible pulse okay
I'm tuckered I'm real tired okay I'm
better now
Oh okey hey buddy
how are you doing hey pal ba Kirino if I
can just get to the door again what I
should have just gone for the door I
should it should just come for the door
I'm gonna wait no if I go for the door
he's gonna he's gonna be right with the
door leads out right okay here we go I'm
going okay I got it here we go use it
okay I did that don't trust your
memories reality is a lie I long for the
sweet release of death okay well that's
a little morbid why was that I need to
remember wait can you feel it will I saw
something big so I'm big over there the
energy that pulsates from the wall I
feel many pulsations and many times
bathe in its power bayview in the
pulsations of an energy oh that that
voice again it feels almost painful to
hear it Oh God the trap is a hedron's
pulse can be used to reveal special
glyphs that can charge it with energy
oh the power is capable of more than you
realize but you must learn to harness it
okay
can I trust my own eyes this can't be
happening I need to remember what
something I don't want to die alone you
die in your sleep you die in real life
you die in your sleep you done in real
life you die in your sleep done really
as you doing you sleep you die in life
okay that's interesting
he looks like a strange blade of some
kind but I can't reach it between the
bars power oh well this is hell is it
ain't so bad so bad about it okay so I
gotta I gotta use this in a circle
I got it
well this a bad idea Oh oh my god oh my
god okay I'm assuming I got blow you up
but I kind of want to see what happens
when I give you a hug first
oh you're stuck oh my god
you're not that stuck I am sorry I I'm
very sorry okay hang on I'm very sorry
about that will I led you wrong I
thought you loose key can I go home -
dagdu I go bye
wait what well what just ran by on the
floor I hate it what is that should I
run away from it
it's just a transport oh this is hell oh
boy I get a dagger tax stunned enemies
okay yeah okay I heard it from my left I
thought that all right well you're gonna
be like that huh gonna be like down I'm
gonna blast you who think I'm gonna
scare to you and nope oh yeah right in
your goiter oh oh thanks I guess ah what
just a dream I doubt that even in my
sleep I can't escape this place oh geez
wait there's that doorknob again hello
baby you don't look so good
it's so Tareq and metallic shard
doorknob I feel strangely warm to the
touch
strange when I woke up I found the same
object from my dream next to me looks to
be some type of jam or shard or
something seems like it's designed to go
into something so maybe I can find a use
for it nightmare the truth I don't
remember ever writing this in my journal
where the hell did this come from
I always scoffed at those who said would
say that ignorance is bliss that drive
to learn the truth and do what I always
felt was right as what pushed me through
most of my life but is the truth always
worth seeking probably maybe not hello
booth there's some secrets here office
games so cool it's just really well made
and it's kind of nice look to it how did
this chandelier fall shame really
oh you know the the Fung Shui of this
living room is death
we messed up I should be able to use the
door that I remove the doorknob before I
fell asleep just doesn't make any sense
that was too sudden for my tastes all
right thank you for this oh there's a
door here now
clewd doorways added these damn doors
litter the halls of the mansion at least
one of these must be accessible so I
should keep an eye out for anything that
sticks out also shouldn't forget to make
good use of the trap to see who can I
open it large metal door with some rust
around the edges looks really out of
place and well wherever I am doors
locked of course it is why wouldn't it
be
there is no mansion or a markiplier
Manor so what you're talking about here
whoa all those yellow fur is they're
gonna thought that was a different look
okay oh is that a door made of skin God
or is is the air around it smells
horrible looks as if it's been put
together with some kind of leather yeah
human leather locked not that I would
want to enter it anyway why does it have
to make that sound Oh
oh hey boy hey buddy
hey hey buddy oh oh oh [ __ ] oh I feel so
tired I just want to get out of this
place okay I thought the floor was gonna
crack there for sure oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait I didn't
boo-boo I just you know probably not
okay I just wanna make sure I wasn't all
represent sure but I just want to make
sure what's out here
[Music]
oh that wasn't it but I oh but now I
guess I should have examined it Oh God
this stone pedestal is in sets in the
top I wonder if it's connected to that
massive platform okay how about this
metallic shard removed
oh that's so cool
my god change my mind close it
put it back that scream that was this
has to be it looks like there are more
slots to fill oh okay oh I love it when
I open the screamy door hello oh who is
it and what is it what is what and what
is who some plain wooden door the smell
of pine floats around it does it now
okay still locked trust safe weird I
felt like I've seen this door before I
don't like you I don't like you what who
are you Tom now will you know the rules
I joined what you of course you know me
my fine friend and I can tell you more
about your situation but first you must
do something for me how about this tell
me what's going on here whoa what's
wrong with your face man this room is my
home and in my home you follow my rules
when talking to me you must be seated in
the chair in front of me treat it like a
game if it helps you understand so
please sit all right but you better
answer my questions afterwards darkness
whatever questions but your face I hate
it why is this the way this works Oh
what me to do that Oh everything's all
fuzzy now what
oh now things aren't fuzzy what the hell
okay let's keep it like this cuz this is
weird talk ah damn it I thought I had
removed that option that isn't available
right now but it isn't like you need it
at the moment
what do you mean what is it supposed to
do the actual process of how it works is
much too complex for your monkey brain
that's racist to put it simply it
creates a dimensional bubble that is
replicated from the current state of the
universe the bubble remains in an
unchanging state and you can shift your
consciousness into it at will however
doing so destroys the Curan universe so
so it's kind of like going back in time
no I guess if you can say that it does
help it if they don't helps you
understand oh but you can't use it
because I haven't set it up yet so leave
that button alone okay save I guess I
already told you that button doesn't
work oh oh that I thought you were
talking about the error button for you
and ow do you know me
I am he who sees through which has been
seen through by not so many I'm a lover
of stories in the fine art of wordsmith
re I'm your one and only true friend in
this awful predicament you find yourself
in okay I feel like you're messing with
me and I'm not really in the mood just
tell me what you know fine fine you can
just call me the safe room guy yeah call
me that will I can offer you help but
you will have to err fine the most
dancers yourself I'm going to give you a
key that goes through a door in the
mansion you need to go through that door
where you'll find its soul trapped
inside you will either destroy this soul
or free it saver destroy his soul
this really is just a game to you isn't
it well an eternity of reading does get
rather dull regardless of how you feel
about what I say you have
other choice yeah this is ridiculous but
I'll hear her you say from guy so say
you're trying to tell me the truth here
how do i free or destroy a soul to save
you must seek out something important to
the soul that reminds them of their
humanity to destroy it you must force
them to repeat their death repeat their
death are you asking me to be a murderer
each soul committed atrocities before
they died so maybe feeling sorry for
them is optional
regardless you will need to go do some
investigating to figure out how to do
either no need to fret about that part
we both know that investigation comes
naturally to you but why is it that I
have to do any of this because you said
so your question will probably be
answered in time probably so here take
the key so I can get back to whatever it
is I do he given to me by safe room guy
okay fine give me the damn key hopefully
I'll wake up soon so this can all be
over with don't treat it like it's a
dream Willy if you do it maybe the blast
when you ever have that was not a threat
by the way mister warning door that son
key unlocks is wide and down some stairs
I think anywho if you need help you can
always come back and see me again okay
thank you I'm gonna go righty-ho here I
go no trust you know honestly I don't
know doji's looks like the kind of door
you'd see in a child's room does a child
live here probably oh it's like that
other game I play a lover of art head
downstairs I want to see if there's
anything over here just a bookcase
although it is embedded into the wall
for some reason and you guys it's
doorway because it's a doorway you silly
Billy
that's because it's a silly-billy
doorway silly okay
here anything important through time and
space he said I'm sure he did some kind
of sci-fi door strange light okay weird
a handgun strange that somebody would
just leave it here like this looks like
somebody left a note
sir will I took the liberty of
retrieving your handgun for you as you
know it won't be able to eradicate the
most capable of wraiths but several
doses of lead should put them down for a
time if you find yourself under assault
with only a bullet to spare well time
shot is their striking should provide a
moment of reprieve also my dear will if
you want to keep your head affixed to
your neck then you must learn to keep
quiet and stick to the darkness you may
find the darkness arduous but it is only
necessary to put out your light sources
when they are within eyesight sound
however has a way of penetrating doors
and thin walls so you must always be
attentive to how much noise you're
making
of course these places you will be
visiting have a tendency to break the
natural laws that govern the world of
man to keep your wits about you and you
should be fine I have a few errands to
take care of but rest assured I'll be
seeing you later
sincerely Johnny this handgun is mine
how's it possible I can't use this
fearing what's yours is bad it is a
destructive tool take it um I don't need
any more convincing stubbornness won't
get me killed
I'll take it despite a damn antagonizing
crystal telling me to okay haven't held
one in quite some time
I should reefa millyar eyes myself with
it
[Music]
I don't want to shoot bang no ammo
figures well you think I want to check
that before I just started Whangdoodle
and guns willy-nilly simple door doesn't
seem out of place like the others paint
does seem a little unusual though okay
so the only one this is the white door
he was talking about what's over okay oh
okay well that doesn't make a lot of
sense but I'm not gonna question it well
I'm talker
alright and door you'd see it as school
whatever you say man whatever you say
are you sure you want to enter this door
well now that you present it as an
option I'm not so sure here we go oh
it's like something out of Silent Hill
oh hey
I hate anymore I hate it even more some
kind of lobby oh I hated the most okay
judging by the side of the door it might
be a janitor's closet okay I don't have
a key for it all right well salmon
seating looks pretty comfy but where is
everyone
good question rustic fireplace reminds
me over cabin by the lake okay slightly
dated elevator smells like electricity
Oh what do you feel den Sierra's in here
will when these spots are revealed
through my power you will see what once
was okay oh my god oh I don't want to
see it again oh no no I'm sorry oh boy
oh boy oh boy
ring the bell can bring it if I wanted
to if somebody's nearby they'll probably
hear it oh no no I thought that might
work
oh this is the way out what is that
thing on the door looks like a vagina
kind of long as this square in Dead
something we placed on like this door if
I'm going to get out of here all right
good smoke seeping out of it and need
some kind of tool and I need a lot of
stuff to deal with a lot of the stuff oh
it was there step 7 let me go off all
the way up first
oh well I thought that was a thing okay
let me go
top geez this axe is covered in blood
and requires someone twice my size to
even carry it but to keep my handgun
ready yeah
you okay something jamming the keyhole
won't open hey Beauty I hear you gotta
tell me twice I guess we're okay go I
guess I'll go
Oh Oh big boy well that guy look like a
firefighter let's go hey wait a minute
hey oh my god ow my head I died okay
thank you I didn't know you'd be that
soon behind me thank you
how am I still alive you know good
question Christ everything seems so real
but not real okay maybe let's not go to
the top floor first let's go somewhere
else
collapse by degree there's one more
level and maybe the monsters not gonna
be on that loop okay this seems cleaner
at least that's nice
Oh hate it hate it here ACK no keys oh
no but an option to hide place reeks I
hope it isn't what I think it is looks
like someone took an axe to this place
Oh funny about that funny about that
funny about that there's some batteries
I guess child's drawing
[Music]
no no no no no no no no hi all right
that's my bad um hello hello there
mister I see you found one of my
drawings my name is Ann Marie who are
you my name is will and I'm looking for
a way to leave this building do you know
how this is a strange question isn't
that what the front door is for well
yeah but there's some type of lock over
the door lock
oh well don't all the doors here have
locks you do know I you can unlock doors
from the inside right I never mind are
there others who might be able to help
me well there's Brennen but I don't
think he likes me anymore oh they're
also all my friends down below gathered
for my tea party you're a strange person
but my friends like strange people so
you should join us
oh thanks for the invite but I don't
have time to play maybe I'll go talk to
this Brennan okay
well I'm looking for a certain somebody
who was always late to tea parties if
you find him be sure to bring him okay
if you do I might be able to get to help
you get out of here I don't maybe I will
we'll see thanks mister bye things were
terrifying me by the way that was just
absolutely horrifying by the way that
was not a joke in any way shape or form
that was goddamn terrifying
I gotta be bit I'll be right back my
food is almost here I'm just gonna leave
this right here if something happens
it's not my fault
oh-oh-oh I came back and we're down here
I'm guessing I'm guessing the died
somehow and I don't know how that
happened
oh hey how you doing hey kid stop
skipping
oh hi we'll have you found my friends
that oh he's definitely not him we need
to find him and take him to the Tea
Party okay oh this is oh my god that's
why are you doing that so what was in
here that killed me is the question
that's the question with the dead okay
so that's the dude doesn't see no no
open hiding space
okay how do I put G for gun reload do I
put combine okay oh my god it makes no
sense when I look out to where the rest
of this room is supposed to be there's
just nothing it's almost as if it
doesn't exist yeah good point so this
isn't real oh oh okay charred key must
go to some other maybe some other
wha-hey who use silly-billy okay
inspect even though the key was found
inside that burned up a two-room I don't
think it belongs to anything in this
room was it left for me intentionally
only of you intentionally we're gonna
come in here was it probably unlikely
okay door unlocked I'm assuming there
was a door unlocked that I just came out
of okay so then I probably got to go up
here okay you're up here yeah okay if
you're up here then that's
bodes well for me okay that's good oh
[Music]
how you doing hello hey I'm looking for
a way out of this place so you guys save
him whoo forever angry mostly it himself
or torture there never ends tragic for
most perspectives not tragic enough for
me
are you talking about something in the
hall what can you tell me about it we
used to be close but that time is long
pissed you find them or you'll find what
you need in his apartment sorry I
stutter his door is locked
but you can get in from above kill that
coward do it for me in the girl Oh
how's this piece of paper not burden oh
hey don't come bursting through that
door don't come bursting through that
door okay glad we'd covered that oh he
oh I gotta go hey that better have been
the sound of you leaving
for be oh hey oh looks like this person
was visually hacked apart I need to stop
staring at before I get sick okay good
point
woo I can charge up and then I can stop
him then I can stun him okay that's exit
PI there's one more door here oh I'll
get that no doesn't seem to be an oh oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] find the box
find the box
listen listen
okay hey
holy ham I lit candles any on a box okay
hey okay well I got all the aminals I
got it I can do I gotta I gotta go I
gotta hide I gotta hide god that's
terrifying
why is that so terrifying it's sold yeah
it's so scary it's so scary it's so
scary
let's just get away from that guy
Oh
is he gone it sounded like he went but
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go over here
because there was another stairwell Hey
holy Sh hey wait no no no he on too
dangerous for that right now
will you she's skipping what are you
worried about if she's a skippity dude
out to the loo
uh-oh it's a different stairwell weed Oh
eyes that's not good Oh Oh a safe room
we will never forgive ourselves check on
Brennan buy more cigarettes uh-huh
big stuff to daddy bear alright alright
whatever I get cuz I can't go man that
looks like a face what is this sound
Oh give a gift you know just get I need
to get our I'm gonna hide scary you
scary ass mother humph
oh you big boy that's your big boy he's
a really big boy
hmm why what I need to call that L there
because I needed to open there's
something stuck in the door give me that
key give me that key give me that
Oh I think just fall out from the guts
okay I got a small key not entering that
room but it looks like maybe the maybe
the elevator is now available let me pop
in here real quick hey buddy hey how you
doing
listen I want to talk to you about
something um so this doesn't work right
is your final warning I got nothing to
say you don't you know it doesn't work
so there's no reason to be in here
unless unless there was something else
hallway on floor a but I don't want to
go to floor a I want to come out of
where I was and I need to go need to go
up I need to go up one more see what's
up here Oh some kind of code okay wait a
minute what is that you see that like
this airflow thing is that important is
that a clue or something I don't know
but I think that the elevator works now
so I'm gonna go try to take the elevator
to wherever the elevator is gonna take
me and then I'll go from there
oh maybe not maybe nevermind okay then
what's this key - says maintenance ah
maintenance wait there's a maintenance
on the first floor okay so maybe I can
just cut through this go down to the
first floor through here I can't I'm
very tired
oh god damn it all I could see anybody
her body by your doing that's the face
oh that's good to know okay how's the
family great I just gotta get downstairs
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh
oh oh oh God okay oh no keep good tip
good run run away bye whoa mud run
runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin
tonight I'm very tuckered okay hang on
am i safe I'm probably not safe okay so
there was a maintenance from right here
there we go ah screwdriver that's
important um birthday card attacked the
wall this probably could code in there
or something maybe birthdays are usually
a code Scrabble more bullets good a
place to hide just in case I need them
okay let's combine this with that okay
that's good clues oh my god there's so
many clues okay uh janitors room
whatever lobby elevator stuck on one of
the other floors it's not working now
exit vent I've got the thing to do that
fire broke out in small residence
eight-year-old in kitchen
okay all right okay okay um
Amory died in a fire along with her
father
okay drawing two firefighters Oh oh I
see what it was a firefighter tried to
save her and then a firefighter didn't
save her
oh so maybe Davidson was a firefighter
okay not father along with Brennan
Brennan is the big guy help us help but
no help came happy birthday 40th
birthday you old fart Ronnie I can't
believe it was in 40 years since that
September January night when mom finally
squeezed you out you should visit soon
she really misses you okay
take lobby change roof password to
something easy to remember tell garrison
new password call al so garrison knows
or maybe that is the password but
garrison knows that's weird okay so none
of these uh all these have been
scribbled out so I'm guessing it's none
of those wait one one one wait 1 1 1 1 1
1 1 1 1 1 1 1
I think it's 1 1 1 1 right
mat that would make sense to me ok so I
got to go back up so up here oh wait a
minute
Hey well hi we'll have you found my
friend is your friend definitely not him
okay what about this one that's him mr.
whitetail you really need to stop being
late can you take him to the Tea Party
out for me I'll meet you down there
afterwards okay okay take to the
basement basement Wow
where's the basement one one no one one
one one oh please tell me this didn't
start before I got that no I have it
okay so it's not one one one one but
that's what's on the note one one one
one unless asbestos how the eyes
might be one three five nine maybe hey
okay that was it oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] gaze into the night pick up
dirty apartment keys okay is that just
saying the keys are dirtier the
apartment that it goes to is dirty oh
you know what I'm gonna gaze longingly
into the night because I thought that
might have been some kind of final
resolution to all this but apparently
not I'm talkin breathin and all this
smoke does nothing good for the lungs
looking out beyond the edge of this
rooftop I can see a single set of
buildings beyond those nothing as if I'm
in a bubble snapshot of something real
out there somewhere must be where my
dream ends okay if you say so buddy but
I don't know how true that might be
might be all kinds of untrue if you ask
me I'm Tucker again nobody's asking me
ooh what is that Oh coin the shape of a
spaceship no room god damn this stupid
big-ass bear let's try it's like got the
inventory management of hey there we go
uh of like some of the Resident Evil
games a small spaceship that I assume a
kids toils oh it's made out of metal and
quite heavy not sure why but it really
looks out of place
dad I'll find my cheese for this unless
I need an oversized paperweight okay
almost bring my hand on the doorknob
well then what was the point oh it's
dark oh yeah dude okay what is that okay
so there definitely is a basement but I
don't know how to get to the basement
also I gotta say I thought this was just
a demo and I think it actually still is
a demo but it's just really oh okay I'm
gonna oh that's that's not the right
person
okay Widow also inspect these uh I may
need to try every door oh god damn it
really okay well I'm gonna do that then
oh there we go got it in it Oh child's
drawing mommy daddy okay that's good
examine book price $59.99 you got it
baby
Oh garrison writing on the front doesn't
seem like anything useful overcoming
addiction of some kind
lots of post-it notes going on here
sticky-notes no real logic most of them
just seemed to be with words of
encouragement okay that's weird
oh damn it these visions it's just sick
no I don't want to see it again
god damn it if I can get by all the
blood it looks like I can work my way
down the hole of that room below if I'm
careful there we go
I wasn't careful Oh God
[Music]
Oh another body this one is different
though sadness anger death this place
reeks of human emotion much like the
rate that wanders the halls hmm might be
worth trying to figure out what happened
here broken bottle found this sharp guy
in room c6 okay gas mask I can't do that
I got to go do this tea party thing
suicide note
I feel that this life one simple [ __ ]
job to save those who need it the most
since that summer day I've withered away
to nothing but a drunkard wasting of a
man
maybe that's all I really have ever been
I failed little anne-marie
poor girl burned death trying to save
her stuffed animal and Tom a talented
musician and friend who trusted me now
just another life wasted by my
incompetence what a [ __ ] friend I was
that couldn't even keep him safe why
should I deserve to live
anne-marie will never play with her toys
again never grow up an experienced life
Tom will never go home to see his wife
and children never plays piano in
another concert hall
I don't deserve forgiveness but I found
a way to get out of all this he said he
can help me all I have to do is give in
illegible after all if I can forget all
of this and find eternal happiness and
why wouldn't I agree
okay hallway for a okay is there
anything else over here
another glass shard that might be
Brennan that might actually be Brennan
like Brennan got it killed himself of
regret and that caused him to be trapped
in this hellscape that I'm in and then
if that's the case then I must have done
something similar because all this seems
to be like little shards of reality
looks like some kind of memorial oh okay
so I got it I got do this basement thing
[ __ ] whoa fast fast lot faster line
faster yes screw you screw you buddy
through you buddy screw you buddy
yeah you got the granddaddy a little
lady hey so where is this basement I
guess it would be down one from the
stairs
that'd be it oh let me also tamper with
this yo maybe this leads to the basement
ah does it do it do it do it do okay
table set table set here okay hey again
mister you can call me Willie Annie
okay then we'll and I thought your name
was will funny although I really can't
tell if you're being serious or not it's
just we'll well well I have good news
oh yeah what's that I have something
that I think will unlock the door you
can have it too but I'm not allowed to
give it to you until you can prove to me
that you deserve it kid I'm not playing
games here if you have what I need them
you need to give it to me sorry mister
I'll be punished if I do that I have an
idea I drew some pictures of me with
Brennan and his friend if you bring
those to me then it will prove that you
understand it you'll be punished
are these your drawings well you have to
you have all of them except one I can't
help for you until you have all of them
though damn it kid I don't have time for
this I'm sorry I want to help but it's
fine I'll find your last drawing
I don't know where that would be boiler
room well this doesn't look happy no
matter what it's it's a death trap for
me to go in here and then die okay I
thought that was something going on
there I guess I haven't also I also
haven't been like exploring with this
thing can you take this goddamn bear off
my hands daaad be great please that go
oh I didn't know this one down oh jeez
wooden beams moon beams oh hey oh sweet
now I got another way in okay but I
still haven't been able to dump these
things I think I probably got to go put
them back where they were if anything
it's the most amazing whoa oh oh sorry
I'm in your house dude and not much of
old [ __ ]
well how about so yes yeah that's right
yeah that's right
Oh
[Music]
i'ma show ya
well that was a big-ass waste of my
goddamn bullets ah [ __ ]
well I shouldn't have done that I got
damn it oh well [ __ ] um
Frick ah [ __ ] okay well I'm perma boned
oh I'm very boned I'm unbelievable I
wasted all of my bullets which is very
wise of me I just got to put these
things back this is where I first met
Ann Marie oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
am i more than just skin um whoa body
appears mutilated beyond recognition
something must have just kept smashing
this man long after he died
smashing okay so I've gotta find it
wasn't in here it's kind of these yeah
this one yeah it was this one okay I'm
gonna put the bear back drop in drop I
don't need either of those I guess I
could have dropped them anywhere well
that was dumb of me I need to find the
last drawing but I need the gas mask for
something I believe and the glass
probably same thing okay so this is the
other side but it's not open this is the
quote-unquote ritual space I'm gonna
take the gas mask
Equipe oh that's good broken bottle Oh
God okay move their their broken bottle
oh it's a weapon all right whatever good
enough for me I don't know how to use it
but pick up glass shard okay well that's
good I guess
all right well now I have these but I
don't think they're they're gonna help
me there's there's some kind of a I
should have died beside them how I wish
I did
[Music]
do you understand well this man lost his
humanity and now wanders aimlessly in
these halls exploit his death and escape
this place this man I I can't afford to
feel for the dead I should do whatever
it is I need to do to escape this place
so this is where the choice lies in
whether or not I feel sorry for this guy
okay I'm gonna drop this Oh really
broken flashlight needs that much okay
I'm gonna drop this for a second I'm not
gonna drop it right on top of that pick
this up let's combine let's inspect this
may I figure out some way to get it to
work let's drop that pick up the glass
shard and equipped it pick up the drop
ship thing okay so there's somewhere in
here a goddamn drawing and I need to
find it
all right don't let me down what wait
what am i doing what
there you are Brennan why did I call
Brennan
brennon please stop I forgive you
remember who you are
he'll then
I know you are I'm sure he forgives you
as well oh I didn't even know that was
gonna do that a photo of two friends Ann
Marie was holding this when she
approached the fireman maybe this is
what I need to get out of this place but
I didn't find the last but I didn't find
the last drawing but I didn't find the
last one I didn't think I did oh if Ida
used the glass shard on him that would
have killed him
maybe maybe she didn't mean the drawings
like these drawings but I think that was
what it was but also there were
scribbles on paintings something like
that Oh
uh-oh I guess that might have been a bug
but I'm not complaining cuz hey I don't
have to wander around forever looking
for last drawing oh geez geez why the
hell is Anne on the wall like that I can
only hope you're at peace now I should
get moving I don't want to be here
there's another metallic shard but
that's what the game is all these doors
they lead to the different little pocket
worlds that these people are trapped in
and this hub I'm in it so I can only
assume that I'm trapped here for some
reason oh you know what I'm gonna pass
that by but what is this well do you
remember what it was like crying over
the loss of a loved one the absolute
pain and despair that seared into your
flesh after that night is left scars for
the world to see trust me when I say
that in the end you can learn to
reconcile with this pain however you
must accept that your actions here have
consequences and I'm glad to see that
you've put yourself on the right path
you've shown empathy for a man who
others would say did not deserve it I
know that things have been rather
terrible for you lately but I also know
that inside you are I'm just man who
wants to see the world become a better
place I must be honest with you and tell
you that I care little of what happens
to the other souls in this place the
only thing I wish to see happen is for
you to come out of this the man that I
know you want yourself to be sometimes
you might just wish for all of this to
end it saddens me to have to tell you
that this is only the beginning of your
anguish however that light inside of you
can make it through the darkness you
just have to not lose sight of who you
are yours truly Walt so there is
something about a weight I took the toy
out of it oh I wonder what the what does
the toy do what do I do with the toy
huh talak shard remove all right one
step closer it's weird
looks like there are more slots than
before is this thing changing no matter
I've got to keep moving well weird well
where do I keep moving to what do I keep
doing where do I go
Oh what you sure you want to enter this
door yes Oh
[Music]
fresh air this is nice I'm sure it'll
turn on nice real soon what is this
maybe this leads somewhere yeah maybe it
does maybe it doesn't well what is that
about if I right-click it it does this
weird like floaty thing what is this
place oh it's a tank I was out of
bullets oh there we go man that was a
hell of a demo please keep an eye out
for our upcoming Kickstarter as well as
the full demo that wasn't the full demo
that was awesome that was amazing that
was like what a demo should be that was
a real sampling of the game that left
you wanting more that's so cool this was
so good honestly truly this was really
really really good I love this it had
all of the feeling that I wanted out of
getting into a world it left me wanting
for more I was exploring it was gritty
gory scary it terrified me the
atmosphere was good the sounds was good
I really want to see this turn into
something big so if there's a
Kickstarter going on right now I'll put
it in the description below like I would
love to see this kind of thing funded
and I would love to see this kind of
game get made it does remind me of
neverending nightmares in a way but with
more like exploration and more and more
feel to it more like a deeper connection
to the world I like it a lot there's a
lot to love out of this I mean it was a
little bit back and forth for a while
there but still kind of like feeling out
the world is part of the game itself so
let me know what you guys think of it
down in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this as much as I did if you
did let me know down in the comments and
just thanks for watching if you want to
help support the channel click that join
button and as always
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]